皆さんこんにちはあかん曲1観戦が3つんです
この子西9でもクザン写館
も来て今日のコンビ等
ぞもう壁てりゃお説教いたしました
今日ベースの皆さんは
国際橋で学生の皆さんも多いと思います
そこでその方々に崩壊したいと思いますがあなたは混ぜ
この
大学に入りましたか
私は思っています大学紹介のパンフレットの招集は図書館を持っています
この図書館で勉強したいと思った人も何か良いと思います
もそうです
空間には人を動かす力があります
見地から私はどうしたら
人が感動し人の気持ちを動かす
建築環境デザインできるかを
ています
なぜ私な環境に着目するようになったのか
私は子どもころから4医学ことが好きでした
公爵も好きでしたーー
チョーク線このは集め家になりたいと考えていました
その私が大学1年生の時
大学祭デー
建築学科の先輩から視認し向けの発表会で手伝ってほしいと頼まれてざいました
その時に行われたプレゼンテーションのスライドショーは
音楽と新九郎 c 科学依存心ポタば肯定的に捉えるのではなく
に瞑想愛という側面もある進路人間の環境は重要だというメッセージを持った
とても感動的なものでした
まあ
そういう意味でですね建築っていうのは
描ける作品も作れ自分が好きなことにもっとできる
そして社会に対して貢献することができると言う
まあ
わたくしにとって今までもっと見なかった選択肢を
心配のプレゼンテーションによって与えられたと思いました
私は
当社の針路を変えて年線が
建築学科に入り
件近いになりたいと考えました
そして件近くに入ったその日を境に
毎日住宅
教会図書硬くの整形課題に取り組みました
ん
私が住んでて家は木造の小さなイビサからけれども
のエア部の設計センスでああ
大きなコンクリートの
2階建ての家を請求しました
哀愁のように描かに行き洋画を見て
海外の
生活の仕方
建築を影響しました
大学を卒業して就職した設計事務所デイ
私は国立ことも送りの仕事を担当することになりました
このプロジェクトは
平成天皇陛下な後退し対2
五関金を記念して作られた国家効果プロジェクトでありました
1965年に横浜1
東京都の境にある約 f 母の
無料の館にオープンしました
そこでその中でピーカン学校
デザインしたのですが生きてん間この委員会学校の
設計監理のためにこどもの国の給料の中ですみ
そして遊びながら時にを進めながら
そして
図面を書き仕事しました
振り返ってみますと人生の中で一番楽しい
だったかもしれません
1,968円に私は
あの事務所を辞め独立し自分の
事務所を起こし規律かとしてへー活動を始めました
こどもくりの仕事して家いいですね
建築だけではなくて
前という環境全体を考えなければならない
ふうに思いました
どのような環境であれば子どもたちが悲しく元気その過ごせるのか研究しその結果を
要したデザインをしたいと考えました
それもいいそのような研究はなかったんです
当時私は
日本大学の芸術学でさえも非常勤講師として教えておりました
学生たちに4家のための読むほうデザインするという課題をホーム化していました
いうも共闘し製作して
でき頭の幼稚園やこういう系に持っていっ
実際にこの街遊んでもない
保育士さんとかあるいは本社の方々も秘宝を受けるというものでありました
学校がよくてもですね
子供たちに人気の雷エイムもありましたし
過去はあまり良くはないんだけれども子どもたちとても人気のあるいう思われました
あるいは小雪さんたちから
危ない生むと評価される本もありました
それを10年間
50ぐらいの
流行を追った
うん
そしてその子供が遊びやすい優遇空間にはどのような要素が必要なのかというモノを
ちょっと研究したわけです
この研究とは別にですね
多くのことに
子供時代に
どこでどれをた遊びをしてそれがどのようなもいくとして残っているのか
こうですねヒアリングし前を変えてもない
遊びの原風景も
調査としてまとめましたその他にも
公園の幼児大調査当然ですねそもそもが
研究を基に外の論文をまとめ
1900が中年の2論貪婪する環境の交渉の研究を
書きました
この研究の結論が夕刊控除という子供の遊びやすい空間
の
+の条件であります
一つは循環機能があると
子供が回遊する道があるということですこれはとてもないんです
2番目にその循環が安全面回飛んだよと
腸の中に
新郎銭高い空間となること
さんっへと4番目に
その樹間に目前を体験できる
の文化があること
うまいというのは9日かまりでやっぱり小さな大処理があったりします
5番目に近道が議論だ
循環が一通りでなくいろんな
yoshi k 様があるということ
の先発先発性があるということです
6番目に床に広場が本気業務とか小さい子ローバー
幹の途中に子供たちが集まりそもそものかた貼ればが必要なのです
最後7番目は全体がポーラスた空間で高設されている
ポーラスというのはたくさん肌が開いているという状態です
子どもたちのかいうのはどこからでもデールができる必要があります
この7つの条件によって子供達が遊びやすい環境
夕刊工場は成立します
私は床構造を持つ区間が1元気すると考えました
それは端的に言いますと尿小屋
関係がしやすい空間です
クロスの初代学者の知恵海軍は
遊びの
雨前の遊びを
肉体的精していいチームアイク状態を楽しむ
体にしています
スペルダイヤプランク
まあ遊園地のジェットこうしたそも
年前のニュー遊びです
私はさらに心の高まりや一体感
高評価もうまいん見栄えに入ると考えています
すなわちワクワクドキドキするような要素が入っているということが重要なのです
そのそれではこう
これからいい
スカー私の代表的な遊間抗争の作品を紹介します
も使う母は
夕刊構造理論を作り上げて最初に
応用した敵をした作品です
1985年
もうことであります地方に大きな普及型の空間があり
戦場に上りながらか言うし
第一から
宇宙までのカークを学びます
これは子ども未来館は八王子方の動静を持った子供のための
博物館です1990年に行きました
建築的な循環の web らんぷ亭
このスライダーにもありますが黄色
家を的な同専門に22回っている全体として建築というのニューム的な巾着です
2005年に横浜へ作ったゆうゆうどもり覚えんです
1回に8時に買いに
幼稚園児のお浴室があり外がをぐるりと
外廊下が回っています
ライブに大北へというがある氷冠構造になっています
2009年にオープンした広島市民球場は600ペーターのメインコースを中心とした
いう感性と約30種類の多様なシートを持つ
てい
新幹線の車内からを
球場内ないフォームのことができます
日に開かれた開放性をある球場であります
アークの優勝はスタジアムの子間と叢書今日のから新聞に書いてくれました
国際経営大学の図書館公民東キャンパスの夕刊構造議論をもとにつくられています
ジョジョ彼はブックコロシアムというコンセプトです
地の東6条です本来
補助彼は頼らなければいけないと考えていました
でも私はを覚ますという行為は知の冒険をすること
冒険は冒険では山や谷が必要だと考えました
この図書館大きな特徴は本番をの後ろに閲覧机があるということです
人を向いている時はプライバシの高い空か
またば終えると森の緑が見えます
子供だったらかくれんぼができるからです
心が落ち着く空間には自然素材が重要だと考えてい
明日質疑を有効に使うことができ
楽しさと落ち着きを与えることができたと考えています
国際教養大の首謀的な建物にない
多くの学生の皆さんに愛され
設計者として大変嬉しく思っております
新しいコンセプトの建築は一人では作ることができません
建築家は自分の思うに作ることができません
自分の設計コンセプトを理解し
沖くれるくらいの遠いて初めて自生します
この
私が設計したら
ブラン城図書館もですね
中いつも耳を前学長がこのコンセプトを理解しているとソップからこそ今までにない
新しいタイプの2冠として実現できたのです
24時間365日オープンの書的な音を燃やされています
この年川中島先生との共同作品といえます
私にとって私のコースエプト理解し
にしていたいか敵の先生もいたということがとても混んであります
私は勇敢構造は子どもたちだけでなく大人たちも楽しく時間を少しワクワクし遊びよく
運動よく学習意欲を高める力あると考えています
そのような痴漢もある空間に出会うと人は感動したり面白がったり
時に困難を乗り越える力を発揮することができると考えています
私は今日皆さんに環境を与えられるだけでなく環境デザインすることの大切さを伝え
たいと思います
自分神の環境を揃えること
それが自分の人生をドライブすることにつながると考えています
空間には
力があることを利用して生活の学習も仕事もより男子フォントができると思います
なんか型地震がデザイナーにならなくても
あなたの彼は良いデザイナー
建築家という家になることは
ハーターから健康の生活を言ってるのために良い医者の言う子を持つということと同様
です
夕刊構造がある今回や環境をぜひアナタの目の前に実現してください
左右私の新しい作品を見せします
仮座にある幼小中の今在庫数しか食えんです
朝熊山音2階建ての校舎でとても自然環境に恵まれています
所感を中心に子どものでは自主的に学習 chrome をつくっていく
創造的でユニークな教育を行っています
せ釣り車んかなど長い時間をかけて話し合いながら作りました
子どもたちが一斉にひたち日友人をたくさん作り
実績だ志をもっ
のナビ遊び
そういう学校です
新しい教育令に基づく床構造物加工空間です
これ図書別内の学校なのというふうに言われるかもしれませんが子どもが寒そうな
ところで遊び腹に探求しています
私は空間には力があると考えています
毎日学校に言うの新しいそういう学校こそ大切と考えています
自分が直接製材しなくても
際だーや検知管に要望して自分の空間や街の環境を変えていくことができます
一志学園のように建築家とのコラボレーションによっていう新しい教育伺い実践でき
ます
私のコンセプトを剥いディア
中島先生が認めくださったように良い愛では思うか人を応援してください
そして自分大楽家族友人そして多くの人たちと共にワクワクした感動を呼びしたい
ふう花と共に楽しい人生を過ごしていくください
ありがとうございました